pour vous définir et surtout pour
résumer votre saison j'ai un seul mot
classe
pas la classe internationale ça vous
l'incarnez mais c'est pas mon propos non
la classe de 3e que vous pensez diriger
le soir
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'en plus vous donner des bons
points enfin un bon point à votre copine
l'autre membre du gang des DDL la
donneuse de leçons parce que les autres
ils prennent des coups de règles sur les
doigts
mais quand même Géraldine moi j'aime
bien quand vous êtes là parce que la
vérité éclate c'est l'exact inverse de
ce que vous pensez
maintenant pour la note je savais pas
quoi faire et vraiment je suis
sentimental j'ai cédé à l'indulgence
c'est tout
[Musique]